it's good honey look it's dope
we got Capri his whole life and his
whole being is stranger than fiction
there's not one aspect of him that I
don't find totally fascinating the fact
that there's a man who held on to his
integrity and who he was his true self
in the midst of incredible oppression
and abuse and an entire culture
basically telling him that he was insane
he didn't see enemies he just saw human
beings with families and and histories
and he was an embodiment of love he was
embodiment of living from a place of
love I really did go from fictional
superhero spider-man to real-life hero
right yeah yeah yeah and you know i and
i loved spiderman i know i always will
he's always gonna have a you know
important place in my heart and in my in
my memory and in my soul but I think you
know spider-man was inspired by
real-life heroes like Desmond so you
know that Desmond to me that the miracle
of Desmond is that he lived and breathed
and walking walked among us and he
didn't have to be you know bit by a
radioactive spider to be to be his
magnificent self